look okay it's not my fault I bet
nothing's ever your fault is it darling
you have thrown away your life working
in some silly Christmas shop this is my
little helper I have nicknamed her lazy
that Africa she appears never to walk so
there's really escape what Jesus what's
your comfort well what are you looking
at your Falcon oh I think you're just
pooed in your eye yeah I think it's good
luck you know what is your boot off my
bed
I'm busy you're weird good bye you've
missed by doctor's appointments
mum is scared so tell me about sleep
never exercise really at all alcohol oh
she's like the pirate okay fine thank
you doctor thank you so much for your
time let's go again
what do you mean again did you follow me
here are elves always so cynical
yes relentlessly these are dark times
I'm Tom Kate
everywhere you murder me so what is it
that you do I sing oh it's amazing
anyway boring boring boring I'm gonna
bored where are you going when that well
you're not homeless no I volunteered why
didn't you just get saved I do to know
4head you were great at your job when
you started right now it's like you
don't care anymore yeah hi hi Kyle I'm a
mess I was really sick and I nearly died
I hope he hooks they get weird but I
don't think you'll get with no I'm just
scared all the time and they just expect
me to be normal but they always like
there's no such thing as normal
it's just being a human being is hard
maybe you should do something nice for
someone deck the halls with boughs of
holly fa la la la la la la la la tis the
season to be jolly oh boy
[Music]
[Applause]
- volunteering the shelter seriously
this sounds like a healthy choice what's
wrong with you I've been trying to find
you you keep disappearing then when I do
bump into you accidentally I might add
it wasn't accidental
[Applause]
why me it's always gonna be here like
I'm gonna make mistakes and that's okay
you're made of everything you do
[Music]
you
[Music]
you